people keep asking if I'm back and I
haven't really had an answers but yes
I'm thinking I'm back
yes that is right our favorite assassin
John wick is back and not only am i
super excited but I am here in New York
on the set of the follow-up to John wick
how do you kind of get back into the
character specifically into the head of
John wick um probably starting when you
start talking talking about the story in
speaking with the director chats to hell
ski what was the second one going to be
about and that kind of starts there just
like what is the guy thinking what is he
feeling what could have happened to him
what happens to him and and then coming
back to the set excited once you put the
suit on what can you tell us about the
story of John Maktoum John wick - uh we
thought for John with - that we'd
revisit the world of the Continental and
it's mostly about the repercussions of
John wick phases for doing what he did
in the first filming and how he
addresses faith karma and consequences
of actions we just took a very surreal
approach the assassin thing and we
created a bit of a world that you know
you can kill eighty four people over a
puppy or burns down your house or steals
your car you have license to you that in
our world we want to give a little wink
wink nod nod to the audience and we get
it it's it's a fun film sit back and
enjoy watch canneries do some really
cool stuff what do you think it is about
this character that makes him so
relatable to all the fans I root for the
guy I root for you see no he just wants
loves his wife you love the dog
I guess people can relate to that he's
like a good guy
for all of these other people who get
this way at the heart of it he's just
like a good wholesome guy you know John
wick is John wick so it's gonna be you
know some John wick yeah haha then
Packers are gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] John wick
is John wick and that's all you need to
say when you are John wick
[Music]
you